[Music]
the scp foundation is responsible for
containing some of the most dangerous
forces in the world without them we'd be
at the mercy of the plague doctor
walking through the world and killing
with a touch anyone could be snapped up
by
scp-106 and drag to a painful death in
his pocket dimension lair there would be
no one to stop
scp-682 from devouring all living things
in sight and no one to hold back the
dreaded scarlet king from breaching our
world and destroying life as we know it
we owe them a lot for sure and they've
earned at least a thank you card and an
edible arrangement but containing the
anomalies of the world comes at a pretty
steep cost they're essentially fighting
a war against a whole host of
world-ending entities and when you're at
war there are bound to be casualties for
some people and creatures out there the
most terrifying monster isn't 096 just
trying to swallow them whole for looking
at its face or 173 just waiting for them
to turn their back so it can snap their
neck for the unfortunates that find
themselves in the wrong place at the
wrong time the scariest monster in the
world is the scp foundation itself a
decade ago the scp foundation was
attempting to recapture
scp-682 which had breached containment
and was tearing its way through the
southern congo region unable to contain
the monster by other means and desperate
to stop it from killing any more
civilians the foundation decided to
implement some rather
extreme measures they deployed a variety
of chemical agents and poisonous gases
in an attempt to slow the creature down
but they had no effect as the enormous
reptile stomped its way toward a nearby
river with a highly populated village
waiting on the other side the foundation
made the decision to take things up a
notch they launched an aerial strike
deploying several aircrafts to drop
explosives on the area around the river
they destroyed large portions of the
riverbank but the environmental impact
was considered to be a necessary evil
when the smoke finally cleared and the
deafening roars of the beast had gone
quiet they stopped their bombing
campaign and dispatched foundation
operatives to the scene there they found
the bones of scp-682 which were quickly
brought into custody before the creature
could begin to heal itself the mission
was considered a success and they were
ready to pull out all of their staff and
head back to the nearest foundation site
when one officer spotted something
floating in the nearby river it looked
like a group of human corpses faced down
in the water their bodies badly burned
concerned that civilians from a nearby
village had been inadvertently present
for the bombing campaign a team of
officers was sent to investigate the
river more closely what they found was
not a group of dead humans but something
else entirely they were all along the
riverbank and floating in the water
approximately 212 specimens of a
previously unknown humanoid species the
bodies were clustered in groups of three
to five appearing to belong to the same
family unit or social group many of them
were frozen in positions of fear or
attempt to defend themselves with some
observing personnel comparing them to
the victims of the pompeii eruption
stuck in their final terrified moments
what appeared to be parents and children
held onto each other some covered their
faces others lay in a fetal position it
seemed that they had known something was
coming to kill them but they did not
have the time or the understanding
necessary to escape it several of the
bodies were removed from the river for
autopsy and examination in order to
understand more about this new possibly
already extinct species they were
humanoid organisms with an
indeterminable genus and species they
resembled tall thin humans with
absolutely no body hair and elongated
limbs the most unusual aspect of the
creatures was in their mouths their
teeth were serrated and sharp resembling
those of a crocodile in spite of these
monstrous teeth an autopsy revealed that
there was no human flesh present in any
of the creatures stomachs instead
suggesting a diet of fish livestock and
whatever else they could peacefully
scavenge every last corpse was removed
from the area and incinerated to prevent
any civilians from coming across them
and asking questions just when the
foundation personnel were finally
packing up and getting ready to leave
the river once and for all they heard
something it was a mournful sound
something between a man bellowing and a
wild animal yelping in pain something
nearby was still very much alive and it
was screaming the officers followed the
sound and spotted one surviving specimen
of the crocodile people lying along the
bank of the river it was holding its
face in its hands curled up into a ball
near the water and it was wailing in
agony there were no visible injuries on
the creature's body but it was clearly
extremely distressed one officer
attempted to approach the creature
calling out to it that he meant no harm
and wanted to get it some medical
attention and looked up at the officer
with wide eyes and its cries went quiet
the officer grabbed his weapon afraid
that the creature might suddenly rush
him but instead it ran into the river it
jumped into the water plunging beneath
the surface and began thrashing around
after a moment of watching its struggle
the officer realized what was happening
the creature was trying to drown itself
he abandoned protocol completely at that
moment diving into the water and pulling
the struggling creature back to shore it
coughed up water for several minutes all
the while trying to crawl back into the
water when the creature had finally
calmed down it was brought into
foundation custody with no further
resistance it appeared to be the last
living member of whatever strange human
crocodile hybrid species was living in
that river and it was designated scp-64
since it was brought into foundation
custody
scp-6415's behavior has been largely
very consistent some scps are constantly
attempting to escape from their
containment or killing an endless
revolving door of d-class personnel but
6415 is not one of those anomalies it is
not aggressive in spite of its
crocodilian characteristics and it's
content to eat the food provided by the
foundation it is fed a diet of raw meat
mostly beef and goat which is provided
fresh daily the foundation was curious
to see if the creature could be pushed
to be aggressive if its circumstances
were made a little less comfortable they
deprived it of food for several days but
it did not seem to notice or even care
much aside from occasionally looking at
the door to see if new food had come
they tried sleep deprivation next
blaring a loud siren sound over the
speakers in the containment chamber
anytime the creature was observed lying
down or closing its eyes it became
listless and visibly exhausted but did
not act out violently at this either
after this testing its ordinary feeding
and sleep schedule was resumed for the
most part all that
scp-6415 does is eat and sleep there is
however one notable exception at random
intervals
scp-6415 will begin to cry sobbing
intensely and appearing to be in a state
of overwhelming distress its cries are
so loud that they can be heard from
several halls away and have caused
hearing damage and personnel in the room
with it there is no way to stop the
creature from crying once it has started
though providing it with a hot cup of
tea a soft blanket or a hug from a
particularly brave and eager d-class has
caused it to cry a bit more quietly once
it is finished crying after several
hours of non-stop weeping it will lie
down on the ground and not cry anymore
for weeks at a time for a time
scp-6415 was considered to be lacking
human intelligence and its containment
procedures were changed to reflect that
it was held in the standard humanoid
containment chamber in the light
containment wing of site 619 with
soundproof walls because it displayed no
threatening behavior it was considered
unnecessary to have any guards placed
outside 6415's chamber however after
incident 6415-01
the foundation's understanding of the
creature changed dramatically the
incident occurred when several d-class
personnel were sent into 6415's
containment chamber to feed it and they
found a harrowing sight on the wall of
the chamber the entity had scratched a
message with its fingernails its
fingertips were bloodied and torn its
hands noticeably wounded from what must
have been a great deal of effort it did
not acknowledge the personnel that
entered the room instead it just sat on
the floor staring at its work on the
wall cradling its injured hands and
crying its shoulders shook with the
force of its sobs and its tears fell to
the ground pooling around it the d-class
personnel were later unable to report
what they had seen without beginning to
cry themselves but eventually calmed
down enough to report what the creature
had written please bring them back it
was a desperate plea for the foundation
to somehow reunite it with its lost
family they had previously thought the
creature to be a simple animal incapable
of understanding its own reality or
communicating through clear language
this proved that the creature understood
very well what had happened to it and
was feeling the loss of its loved ones
fully one d-class officer noticed a
scrap of paper likely a piece of butcher
paper from one of the creature's
previous meals with a picture drawn on
it it was a crude sketch but its subject
was easily recognizable it was the
southern congo river where 6415 was
first discovered with three creatures
splashing in the water the largest one
resembled scp-6415
and it was swimming alongside a slightly
smaller adult of its species and a much
smaller creature that appeared to be a
juvenile of the same species context
clues indicated that this was a drawing
of
scp-6415's family its partner and their
child at first the foundation
researchers were uncertain who exactly
the creature was referring to in its
initial message but this drawing made it
perfectly clear it wanted its family
back it is uncertain whether or not the
creature is aware that its family is
dead but it clearly feels their absence
just the same and believes the
foundation might have the power to end
its suffering foundation personnel who
were exposed to the details of the
incident became inconsolable falling
into a deep bout of depression brought
on by a sense of shame and
responsibility when counseling sessions
proved ineffective the emotionally
affected staff were given amnestics to
wipe their memory of the incident and of
6415 altogether one employee research
assistant sheryl crews attempted to
release the creature from its
containment insisting that it deserved
to roam free however when she opened the
door to its containment facility the
creature made no move to leave it just
stared at her tears in its eyes as if it
knew that it had nowhere else to go
research assistant cruz was given a
powerful amnesic and relieved of her
position at the foundation her current
whereabouts are unknown in order to
prevent any more reckless behavior from
sympathetic staff the message scratched
into the wall was painted over and the
sketch recovered from its chamber was
destroyed but even if the memories and
evidence of the creature's pain are gone
anyone walking by its chamber can still
hear it weeping it is uncertain what the
containment procedures for
scp-6415 will become it is not simply an
animal and clearly understands language
though it appears to be incapable of
speech if it could talk whatever it said
would surely be heartbreaking for now
the entity remains in itself serving as
a grim reminder of the guilt that weighs
on the foundation's conscience no matter
what they do with 6415
they cannot take back what they did they
cannot lift the weight of the creature's
grief or bring back its lost family it
is the lone survivor sitting in its
foundation cell weeping for its broken
heart and begging the foundation for the
one thing it can never do bring them
back now go check out
scp-1762 where the dragons went and
scp-348 a gift from dad for more
heart-wrenching as cps